[Music]
a toothpaste brand claims their product
will destroy more plaque than any
product ever made a politician tells you
their plan will create the most jobs
we're so used to hearing these kinds of
exaggerations in advertising and
politics that we might not even bat an
eye but what about when the claim is
accompanied by a graph after all a graph
isn't an opinion it represents cold hard
numbers and who can argue with those yet
as it turns out there are plenty of ways
graphs can mislead and outright
manipulate here are some things to look
out for in this 1992 ad Chevy claimed to
make the most reliable trucks in America
using this graph not only does it show
that 98% of all Chevy trucks sold in the
last 10 years are still on the road but
it looks like they're twice as
dependable as Toyota trucks that is
until you take a closer look at the
numbers on the left and see that the
figure for Toyota is about ninety six
point five percent the scale only goes
between 95 and 100 percent if it went
from zero to 100 it would look like this
this is one of the most common ways
graphs misrepresent data by distorting
the scale zooming in on a small portion
of the y-axis exaggerate a barely
detectable difference between the things
being compared and it's especially
misleading with bar graphs since we
assume the difference in the size of the
bars is proportional to the values but
the scale can also be distorted along
the x axis usually in line graphs
showing something changing over time
this chart showing the rise in American
unemployment from 2008 to 2010
manipulates the x axis in two ways first
of all the scale is inconsistent
compressing the 15 month span after
March 2009 to look shorter than the
preceding six months using more
consistent data points gives a different
picture with job losses tapering off by
the end of 2009 and if you wonder why
they were increasing in the first place
the timeline starts immediately after
the US has biggest financial collapse
since the Great Depression these
techniques are known as cherry-picking a
time range can be carefully chosen to
exclude the impact of a major event
right outside it and picking specific
data points can hide important changes
in between even when there's nothing
wrong with the graph itself leaving out
relevant data can give a misleading
impression this chart of how many people
watch the Superbowl each year makes it
look like the events popularity is
exploding but it's not accounting for
population growth the readings have
actually held steady because while the
number of football fans has increased
their share of overall viewership has
not finally a graph can't tell you much
if you don't know the full significance
of what's being presented both of the
following graphs use the same ocean
temperature data from the national
centers for environmental information so
why do they seem to give opposite
impressions the first graph plots the
average annual ocean temperature from
1880 to 2016 making the change look
insignificant but in fact a rise of even
half a degree Celsius can cause massive
ecological disruption this is why the
second graph which shows the average
temperature variation each year is far
more significant when they're used well
graphs can help us intuitively grasp
complex data but as visual software has
enabled more usage of graphs throughout
all media it's also made them easier to
use in a careless or dishonest way so
the next time you see a graph don't be
swayed by the lines and curves look at
the labels the numbers the scale and the
context and ask what story the picture
is trying to tell
[Music]
you